I give you wanda and vision marvel studios
first original series arrives on disney plus
we just don't know what to expect in
five days something's wrong here wanda
the universe the avengers is expanding
we have everything under control
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new Wandavision video they gave away the first
three episodes to people to check out and do
early reviews for so we'll do a breakdown of
that and explain what kevin feige said about
the series during all of his interviews he had
some funny things to say about marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5 the x-men the mutants of it all
there was a lot that he said in a lot that he
did not say or said that he could not talk about
because of big spoilers he didn't want
to pull a full tom hollander mark ruffalo
but i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
so be sure to subscribe to get everything this
is going to be the year where marvel almost
has a brand new show or a brand new episode
every single week all year long it's going to be
crazy 2021 already so much better than 2020 we'll
also do a giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber
and let me know what kind of x-men easter eggs
you want to see during Wandavision so one of
the biggest things that we actually found out is
that the first three episodes are actually only 30
minutes each way shorter the later episodes get a
little bit longer but it's basically just like the
mandalorian only Wandavision is nine episodes
instead of the eight that the mandalorian had
all the different marvel disney plus series will
have different episode counts they won't all be
exactly the same but when we get to falcon and
winter soldier episodes and then loki episodes
and the rest of the shows later this year i
wouldn't be surprised if all the marvel disney
plus series are mostly the same in that regard
in that all the episodes are going to be around
the same length as the mandalorian episodes like
they're just programmed for that particular link
because of the amount of money that they spend
on the series the other big reason why the first
couple of episodes are so short is because they're
doing the sitcom tropes and they want to be as
period specific as possible as accurate to what
it would have been had they've been making the tv
shows back during the 50s the 60s and the 70s and
so on and during those eras of television sitcoms
were traditionally only 30 minutes long sometimes
even less than that because of all the commercials
and speaking of commercials this is actually
pretty cool to be as accurate to the period as
possible for each of the different sitcoms that
they were parroting the Wandavision episodes
do include classic sitcom commercials during the
episodes but the whole thing is the ads themselves
are meant to be clues and easter eggs for the
story like other stuff will be happening during
the commercials while they're also selling you
products that are supposed to be specific to each
of those different decades like the commercials
themselves are mostly more meta commentary for the
story with a bunch of marvel avengers easter eggs
like obviously this is all a fake reality around
her we know what's real we the audience but she
envisioned are actually buying into the lie as if
they actually were living inside a sitcom and they
didn't know that they were inside a sitcom i did a
loki trailer video a little while ago talking
about how there's a bunch of rick and morty
references and stuff that they're borrowing from
that series in the way they made the loki episodes
but they're also kind of doing that within the
Wandavision series as well where say like in rick
and morty rick knows that he's inside a television
show he can break the fourth wall in that way
there are moments during Wandavision where you
start to see that like the reality cracking around
her this house of m style reality that she creates
for herself so even though it seems like she's
completely drunk her own kool-aid so to speak like
oh wow this life that i'm living is so amazing
that i'm creating around me she also at times
does acknowledge that she's inside a fake reality
it's just that it's so funny to watch commercials
from that era the 50s 60s and 70s like the i
love lucy commercials because there's so much
sitcom stuff happening during the first part of
this series they actually got jaleel white to
moderate their panel that's right steve urkel
from family matters one of the most notable 90s
sitcoms actually did the marvel panel and one of
the other reasons why they dropped the first three
episodes is because most of those are heavy with
the sitcom tropes and only part of the series
will be doing the sitcom thing before it kind
of turned into this bigger avengers wtf event
series kevin feige actually said the way they
market the series the way they're selling it to
everyone with all the trailers the way they're
building this out was heavily influenced by the
way the mandalorian and the star wars people
sold that show he said that they did such a good
job of building that as a huge event series that
it's completely influenced the way that they're
selling all these marvel disney plush shows to
audiences the exception to that obviously is that
Wandavision they're just building is this super
weird series in the best possible way the
weirdest thing you've ever seen the mcu do
is sort of like the legion tv show on fx obviously
that was an x-men tv show inside the marvel
universe but it was being made by jeff loeb in the
marvel tv people not by the marvel studios people
and kevin feige now the difference is is that all
the tv shows are coming from kevin feige in marvel
studios the movie people that's why all the movie
actors are coming back to play their characters
but Wandavision is very much a legion type
of tv show where you're not quite sure what's
real at times and they play with perspective and
people's viewpoints only because this is obviously
all about scarlet witch and vision it's mostly
from scarlet witch's perspective that's why they
call the tv series wanda vision it is literally
her vision as she's watching all these things
but obviously the title is also a reference
to a couple other things like wanda and vision
because it's their life together referencing the
comic book that was all about their relationship
but also the sitcom tropes of the decade like
Wandavision in television you're watching tv with
the name of actual tv sets and even though they're
doing a lot of the sitcoms stuff and it seems kind
of silly it does go dark at times when they start
referencing a lot of twilight zone tropes from the
rod sterling version of the tv show the classic
twilight zone and i referenced the legion x-men
tv show when asked about all the marvel phase 4
x-men mutant stuff of it all kevin feige wasn't
very forthcoming he didn't want to give away
too many big spoilers like i said he doesn't
want to join the spoiler bros with tom hall and
mark ruffalo and now chris pratt apparently too
but overall the creators did acknowledge that the
series borrows aspects of all the biggest scarlet
witch comic book runs through the avengers the
vision scarlet witch miniseries that cover their
relationship the birth of their children as we
see during all the trailers the white vision
resurrection storyline where they brought him back
to life avengers disassembled where she starts to
go a little bit nuts then full-blown house of m
where she creates a whole separate reality for
herself and the follow-up sequel story to that
the ending where reality starts to crack around
her and crumble until she finally utters her
famous no more mutants line so in that same way
her storyline through the episodes progresses like
her storyline through marvel comics but the series
isn't adapting exact versions of those stories
just aspects of them so if there are scenes or
easter eggs that seem like they're referencing
those big comic book stories it's completely
intentional like even elizabeth olsen when she
was going on the talk shows the last week was
asked about the wine bottle house of m easter egg
and she's like you know that would be very clever
if our prop master and our set designer did that
like she's saying i can't give away spoilers but
yes that's totally intentional i know a lot of you
been asking about quicksilver showing up during
the series well the whole thing with this series
is that they're addressing all the storyline
they're dealing with all the past trauma that they
never had the time to do in the other big avengers
movies like after he dies during avengers age of
ultron you see her just completely lose it briefly
but then in sort of the post-credits scenes they
never really address it and they never address it
again during captain america civil war or avengers
infinity war or avengers end game so one of the
reasons why Wandavision was one of the first
series that they wanted to do during marvel phase
4 is because there was just so much of her story
that had been untold in the mcu movies all the
actors are fantastic i mean you've seen elizabeth
olsen paul betty in all the avengers movies you've
seen their other movies as well too so you know
what they're capable of but monica rambo the way
they treated the agnes character who's basically
their version of agatha harkness from the comics
they were all fantastic like catherine hahn is
amazing she fits perfectly into all the tropey
sitcoms stuff but also works really well when the
series goes full blown crazy town avengers level
thinking about further on x-men stuff happening in
the mcu kevin feige was asked when marvel phase 4
is supposed to end because they've announced so
many movies and so many tv shows people want to
know when is phase 4 ending and when does
marvel phase 5 begin because marvel phase
5 is really when people expect to see the new
rebooted versions of all the x-men characters
and typically each phase of marvel movies has
ended with a big avengers team-up film like the
first avengers movie avengers age of ultron
avengers infinity war and avengers end game
and as you can see here avengers 5 isn't anywhere
on their current movie release schedule so people
are just wondering when the transition is going
to happen feige basically did his version of the
old man captain america meme no i don't think
i will tell you when that's going to happen
my assumption based on a lot of the castings
and the rumors for the movies that are later
in the schedule that we know about like black
panther 2 the new fantastic four movie is that
marvel phase 5 will begin around those movies
particularly the new fantastic four movie either
at the end of that or at the beginning of that
and during marvel phase 5 that's when we will
see the full-blown rebooted x-men mcu movie with
new versions of the characters deadpool 3 is kind
of an exception to that because it's going
to be a little bubble of its own continuity
technically part of the mcu but also technically
kind of doing its own thing the only reason why
they can get away with that with a deadpool
character is because he can comment on a lot
of the inconsistencies like he can actually make
jokes about the mcu and whether or not he's in
the mcu but i think they've done a fantastic job
with marketing the series and hyping up how weird
it's going to be so the people aren't surprised
when they go into the first couple of episodes
and it gets really really weird and even though
kevin feige confirmed big crossover with doctor
strange too multiverse of madness he wouldn't
give too much away about exactly how that leads
up to doctor strange too but when they actually
start releasing the episodes to everyone and i do
my full episode videos i'll start pointing those
easter eggs out things referencing the multiverse
and how that's all going to spill into the other
marvel phase 4 movies and influence the plot of
what's happening during marvel phase 4 in general
this friday both episode 1 and episode 2 will be
released at the same time so i don't know if i'm
going to do my episode 1 and 2 video together is
a super video or i'll break that up into two
pieces but as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you'll see all those episode
videos it'll be just like the mandalorian series
so leave all your requests in the comments below
i'll name a giveaway winner when i post my next
big marvel video everyone click here for that
Wandavision episode 1 opening scene video and
for all you avatar the last airbender fans there's
been talk of a new animated series happening click
here to learn all about that thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!